Speaker 1: Let's speak next to Eduardo
from Brooklyn. You're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Hello. Welcome back.
It's nice to have you back. Thank you. There
is a question I've always been meaning to ask
you, really. And it's, you know, the content
of your show always kind of led me to want to
ask you this. Why is it hard to put critical
thinking into the curriculum of US schools?
Speaker 1: I don't know that it is hard,
I mean, I'm open to the idea that it's difficult,
but I think it's more about there's not
there's not I think there's a couple of things
going on. One, there's big political resistance
to it in some states. And the number
two, I think right now in most schools,
particularly K through 12. Everything's
just kind of sliced up nice and cleanly
in terms of what people teach, it's like, OK, this
is the world of math and then this is the world of
science. And here we're doing language and here's
history. I don't know. I mean, I think media
literacy would fall under media studies. Lots of
schools have no media studies. So my guess is that
also probably is an impediment to some degree.
Speaker 3: No, I agree. And, you know, I should
preface that question with the fact that I studied
in the U.K. and I graduated my high school diploma
was an international baccalaureate, I'm sure. But
it critical thinking was a two tier class that I
had to take to graduate. And I it helped me a lot.
And, you know, you refer a lot to Marcus Aurelius
and, you know, Cinecitta, younger things that I
had. I was using my curriculum to read, right?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I would be
shocked if I don't even know, like,
would it be an exaggeration to say 10 percent of
of of high school graduates know about Seneca and
Marcus Aurelius? I mean, I don't even know
I don't want to understate or overstate,
but it's not looking good. That's the point.
Speaker 3: That's fair. Yeah. Well, have you on
the phone let me just note one thing. I thought
your interview with Mike Lindale was fantastic.
Oh, thank you. I have very limited sympathy for
him, but it's still a little bit of sympathy
because he's indoctrinated to a horrible point.
Speaker 1: But, yeah, he's so out of his mind.
And, you know, some people wrote to me and they
said, David, sir, I was disappointed because you
should have been taking each thing Mike Pelo said,
and crushing him and blow out a letter like that.
That's not how the guy is so disconnected from
reality. It was almost like a performance piece
showing how disconnected from reality he is. If I
start arguing about each thing, he loses his mind.
It would be funny, but I'd get four minutes
out of him instead of a half hour. You know,
Speaker 3: you'd be adding nothing. And it's I
think it was just more interesting to see, like
an interview that you controlled your you take him
Speaker 1: seriously, right. Or I'm
pretending to take him seriously.
Speaker 3: Exactly. You know, right. I mean,
you know, sort of he believes that you take
him seriously. Yes. And at the same time,
you know, he he exposes himself instead
of you having to go on the attack.
Speaker 1: That's the idea with those. That's
the idea. Yeah. I appreciate you seeing it for
what I thought it was anyway.
Speaker 3: Yes. And, David,
thank you. Very nice to have you back.
Speaker 1: All right. Eduardo from Brooklyn,
great to hear from you. What a series of
very solid phone calls today. I have to
tell you guys, it's really been going quite well.